dozens of Israeli Air Force pilots have
threatened to boycott military training
in protest against the government's
proposed judicial reforms thousands have
been demonstrating against Plans by
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu to
severely limit the power of the Supreme
Court
who said pilots who refused to serve
would put Israel in danger
ous
when we fight on the battlefield and
look lift and rights we don't do so to
check the political views of our
brothers and sisters we look right and
left knowing that we're storming
together shoulder to shoulder against
our enemies to ensure our security and
their future in a public struggle
there's room for protists there's room
for disagreements for expressing
opinions but there's no room for refusal
Imran Khan is live for us now from West
Jerusalem Imran how worried would
Netanyahu be by this threat to strike
coming from the Armed Forces
well he's been tweeting about it I'm
going to paraphrase his tweet it's quite
extraordinary actually he sent her a
picture of himself as a young Soldier
saying uh when the reservists uh are
called we answer that's how worried
about uh this that he is he's actually
putting himself uh in the frame for this
it is unprecedented uh Laura this is
something that Israel has never seen in
its history uh before now 37 out of 40
pilots in the 69th Squadron this one of
the most crucial squadrons
um in the Israeli Air Force have decided
that they're not going to show up for a
briefing on Wednesday instead they're
going to use the day to talk about the
political situation in the country
that's never ever happened before here
in Israel now it's worrying for two
reasons for the government firstly uh
it's worrying for operational capability
if Pilots are refusing to fly then that
has a knock-on effect for Israel's own
security and remember this is a Security
State right
the other one is a social cohesion
um the Army has long uh established
itself as being apart from politics it's
a National Institution it's a
nationalistic institution people are
very proud of the Israeli Army uh in
Israel itself and the image abroad the
the Israeli Army presents of being one
that is in defense of the nation so to
see these uh fishes these gaps are
appearing within the Army itself within
the military structure itself is very
worrying now there are senior commanders
who are looking at the situation and
they simply don't know what to do
they're caught between a rock and a hard
place they don't want to put pressure on
uh the pilots and The Navigators
themselves to court to come for Duty
because that'll be seen as political
interference and the rights to rights to
protest however the government is
putting pressure on the senior
commanders in order to be able to keep
uh the Army intact and heart like I say
as a nationalistic institution so it's
unprecedented they're navigating it no
one really knows how this is going to
play out but the bigger worry about all
of this is it just won't be one Squadron
which it is right now that it could
spread that these protests within the
military could get wider and wider very
interesting story to keep across for the
moment Imran thanks very much